il y aura les deux classes de 6e de
l'époque quoi ces vaches pour sa part
d'organiser ça au collège en même temps
c'est barré du collège experts ont pu
les voir aller au psv compagnie puisque
ce n'était peut-être pas les mecs les
plus cools à l'époque maintenant
regardons a réussi bien on va leur
montrer pour être comme d où qu ils vont
nous voir arriver
[Musique]
sur ces candidats gauthier la banque de
l'opep mais genre tu veux lui donner à
ce soir qu'est ce que ça a changé c'est
dingue et le matin jonathan on amoureux
du collège
jonathan lopez toujours étant lopez
le dur à cuire qui me prend pour lopez
bas et des français ou quoi c'est pour
toi mon lopez luis lopez le game
commence
[Musique]
je crus de bodmer va on s'est battu
toute ma vie pour prouver la terre
entière qu'on n'était pas des tocards
vous êtes prêts pour la contre attaque
[Musique]